[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show many people
waiting at the edge of their seat for
pat's coved uh well my screen just went
black for a second that was weird pat's
positive or negative covet diagnosis we
still don't have it uh really a
testament to the sad state of testing in
the united states that it's been three
days you don't have your results yet
yeah three days at this point i'd
imagine i get the results today yeah but
in hindsight i should have maybe done an
at-home test as well as a pcr test
so then i would have at least had some
idea if i was positive or negative and
of course waited for the pcr test
results but i think regardless even if i
do test negative i'm going to wait it
out a few more days because given the
fact that i have some symptoms there's a
chance that it would be a false negative
sure so i'll just wait it out it's not
too bad quarantining you know just
focusing on work and uh maybe working
out from home and that sort of thing
sure it's hunkering down for a little
bit longer it's not too too bad but
we'll have to wait and see uh what the
results are particularly with omicron
the home tests seem very very suspect
now you do have symptoms with with
asymptomatic
omicron the home tests seem
really unreliable with symptomatic i
think they are more reliable but in any
case i guess we'll know soon
we've talked about how if you're
vaccinated and boosted the and you get
omicron 75 of the time you're not going
to have symptoms i wonder if i really if
i do have it if i do fall into that 25
of people who do get symptoms or maybe
if those numbers are understanding
so the 75 is
if you're boosted
you have a 75 protection against
symptomatic omicron that doesn't mean
75
of cases are asymptomatic
but in any case you have symptoms
so i don't know what we learned from
that so then if i walked into a room
with a bunch of people who had omicron i
would be 75 percent protected
is that what you're saying instead of
if
no no
you know it's it's kind of complicated
to explain
let's first see if you're positive and
then we'll assess the probabilities of
it being the scenario that we'll take it
from there we'll take it from there
exactly yeah um okay let's talk about
the u.s russia talks we we heard such
um uh boisterous
uh speculation about what would happen
at these u.s russia talks they've taken
place
there was no progress made on the issue
of tensions over ukraine
and the talks have ended um there were
several hours of calls yesterday seven
hours in fact there were no specific
negotiations
they are reportedly no closer to
resolution
over the fear
that russia is going to attack ukraine
uh invade ukraine and there were press
conferences yesterday after the talks
uh officials on both sides said they
were constructive
and the next step is a round of
negotiations or of conversation rather
at nato's headquarters
tomorrow now you know pat i am very open
to the idea
that this is all kind of um
action from putin
to get a reaction
and maybe use that as leverage i am
totally open to the idea that putin
doesn't really plan to invade ukraine
but there are people denying that russia
is has even moved military assets to the
border
there doesn't seem to be any credible
reason to to question that at this point
we have the satellite
russia has moved troops to the border
the question is is it real
in terms of its intent to invade or is
it is it a ruse of some kind yeah i
doubt that there's any immediate attempt
to
invade or any plans to invade maybe this
is the type of thing where they want to
play a long game so they move the troops
and then six months down the road a year
down the road that's when they choose to
actually move the troops in
but it seems like maybe some of the
concessions that putin wants are to get
it so that georgia and ukraine never
join nato right and maybe just the
threat of putting troops on the border
of ukraine is enough to get that
concession because obviously we're very
war-weary and nobody wants to be going
to war especially with russia such a
major force and not at this time when we
just ended this 20-year conflict in
afghanistan and most americans don't
want to do anything having to deal with
war in these foreign countries anymore
so yeah that's probably what they're
trying to do and putin knows that he can
take advantage of this situation now and
flex while he can i think that's
probably what we're seeing here at the
same time a different
interpretation would be
if you
don't want nato to believe
they need to accept ukraine
in terms of self
shared defense
don't make it seem like they're going to
have something to defend themselves from
right like that would be another
plausible interpretation which is if you
don't want ukraine and nato
don't mass troops at the border
making it seem like nato might actually
have to come to ukraine's defense i
don't know i could see both
interpretations
and i also wonder what an actual
invasion of ukraine by russia would look
like because i think in our minds we
picture troops just walking through the
country sort of like we've seen before
you know you think back to like world
war ii era yeah where you have nazis
crossing belgium or something like that
i don't know if it would necessarily be
something like that or if it would more
be places in ukraine that are more
russia friendly russia speaking maybe
elements of their government that are
more russia friendly would welcome in
russian troops and so that they're like
speaking to one another and then they're
welcomed in um and you know maybe they
just spend enough time there where they
can slowly take power from within and
then once they've taken over the russia
uh russian-speaking areas then they can
sort of consolidate and eventually
persuade other parts of the country to
join them like maybe that's what we
would see there sort of like a slow
movement rather than a full-on attack
with guns firing and everything like
that i agree that using a 70 year old
framework for what it would look like 80
year old
is probably
inaccurate i i don't really know what it
would look like and of course i'm
hopeful that it doesn't happen so that's
the latest and then tomorrow there will
be the next round of discussions at nato
headquarters and maybe by thursday we'll
have more information for you this is an
incredible story a maryland man has now
lived three days with a pig's heart
beating inside his chest the surgery
took place at maryland medical center
this was a gene edited pig
used as an organ donor the recipient is
dave bennett 57 years old he is the
first human to risk this experimental
surgery
um
it was a nine-hour surgery where doctors
replaced his heart with one from a
one-year-old
240 pound pig
gene edited and bred exactly for this
the recipient is breathing on his own
without a ventilator he is on an ecmo
machine which does about half the work
of pumping blood throughout his body and
he'll hopefully be slowly weaned off of
that where the pig's heart will do all
of the work of pumping the blood
throughout his body this is something
that
has been theorized for so long use
animal organs
to save human lives
there's more than a hundred thousand
people waiting for organ transplants
side effects symptoms many die waiting
in vain for someone else to die quite
frankly so that they can get an organ
pigs have organs that are very similar
to humans
uh and obviously if you could start
breeding pigs for organ transplants it
would be an incredible thing in terms of
saving life it's called
xenotransplantation and this is a major
major leap forward now
what happens in five days what happens
in 10 days we we don't know this is not
a guy who's out of the woods i think is
important to mention yeah this guy is
essentially a guinea pig in this
experiment how long have you been
waiting for that i just came up with it
so you know just a few minutes but yeah
i thought that was pretty good yeah i
mean as you point out uh more than a
hundred thousand people sit on these
organ transplant wait lists and about 6
000 people a year die waiting for an
organ that just never comes be it a
heart or a kidney or a lung and so yeah
i mean you can't it's really not
scalable i think uh especially when
there are these other options to have it
be so you have to have someone die
suddenly in order for them to become an
organ donor if you can make it so that
pigs or these other animals are raised
even if they are gene edited and even if
it's the not the most moral thing
necessarily uh if you can maybe sort of
substitute the current system that we
have for that i think that's definitely
a step in the right direction so that's
an interesting point though you don't
eat you're vegan you don't eat pork i am
not vegan i don't eat pork
what is your
sense of this in the context of veganism
because you've gotta gene edit and raise
the pig and then of course you've gotta
kill the pig when you take the heart
yeah i mean it's not great but i think
you have to be on team human at the end
of the day wow right so if this is going
to extend this person's life who knows
15 20 30 years then you have to sort of
take a utilitarian approach and say that
you're for it it's just unfortunate how
in the meantime there's probably going
to be a lot of trial and error and a lot
of pigs are going to be killed
needlessly and maybe some of those
organs won't be put to good use but i
mean that is the scientific process
after all we do this for so many
different things already and i think
it's unfortunate in a way but i think
overall it does good so in other words
you and i agree with you if this is your
view you see see it as different where
humans can easily survive without eating
pork yes but absent someone dying and
giving you
an organ
this is actually a way where absent the
pig heart
a lot of people would actually die yeah
it's a matter of necessity in the same
way if you were starving in the woods
and you couldn't find any fruits or
vegetables to eat but there were some
wild pigs running around i would support
your right to go and kill that pig to
eat it
so if someone needs a pig heart to live
and they otherwise are going to die from
it i feel like it's okay to
kill the pig in order to take the heart
from the pig that's just my sort of
assessment of it there it is
blog.patford.com
pigs you can find more about that no i'm
kidding uh no that's interesting i think
that there's a lot of vegans who would
agree with you and i think that there
are many who would not
yeah that's probably fair to say yeah
which is probably true on almost any
topic with any group uh but an
incredible achievement now the hope is
we get past three days and we get to
seven and then we get to 30 and that
this is someone now that can that can
live
uh a long life that that would be an
incredible thing and we'll we'll keep
following that
um senator john ossoff is going to
introduce a bill
barring members of congress from trading
individual stocks this is something
nancy pelosi has already said she is not
interested in senator john ossoff says
that's exactly what he's interested in
it would apply to members currently
serving in office and their immediate
families it turns out that
the stock act which is sort of meant to
prevent
these types of conflicts of interest in
terms of legislators acting on
information they learn through their
being legislators to make stock moves
there are dozens of lawmakers violating
the stock act and senator john ossoff is
looking to sort of cut this off at a
higher level by saying
if you're a member of congress you can't
hold or trade individual stocks while in
office you can hold mutual funds
and mutual funds the belief would be
they react in a much more general way to
whether the economy is doing well or not
whereas individual stocks can much more
easily be the subject of manipulation
through legislative decisions i think
that this is completely reasonable
i don't think it's going to pass i don't
think there's any interest in the the
the majority of the house and senate in
doing this but we've said for a long
time pat that the privileged positions
that allow
these members of congress to find out
about so many things and it is rife for
abuse and we've seen it abused it makes
perfect sense to me yeah this has to be
done it seems so incredibly obvious it's
interesting to see john ossoff buck the
trend i suppose or at least buck some
sort of a democratic leadership because
nancy pelosi of course was so against
this yeah and she's made an incredible
amount of money off of her investments
over the years so i wonder if this will
be seen as like the new democratic
position amongst most and if this
actually could get some traction
obviously you have to rely on lawmakers
getting rid of their own power in some
sense and so are they going to be
willing to do that probably not you're
probably not going to get the numbers in
order to make this sort of thing pass
yep um but you know even if you
say okay they can't have individual
stocks anymore there still can be plenty
of conflict of interest like if you
think about the covet crash for example
many of these lawmakers knew that there
was going to be an economic calamity
coming and so you know many chose to
sell off many of the etfs and mutual
funds that they had um knowing that they
could buy it back up cheaper after there
was a crash so yeah and that is
conflicting right even that would be
seen as bad but i don't know how you
necessarily go after that because in a
sense you'd have to say okay well these
members of congress they can only hold
cash they can't be invested in these
other assets which just right doesn't
seem all that fair starts to seem sort
of unreasonable right you could you
could short the entire market through
etfs or mutual funds or whatever the
case may be the closing of the spousal
loophole that john ossoff is proposing
is also interesting nancy pelosi's
husband
has a massive stock portfolio in
companies like netflix alphabet which is
google salesforce slack etc
and
without the spousal loophole nancy
pelosi or whoever we're picking on her
because she's known to have calls puts
all these different things and her
husband very very involved in stock
trading she could just go to him and say
hey listen you should buy this or you
should sell this she would technically
be in compliance by not doing it herself
so closing that loophole seems important
i don't think pelosi is being
specifically targeted by asif it just so
happens she would be swept up if a lot
of these things were to be made law
yeah are you surprised that she's not
willing to at least
uh say that she supports this because
it's such a bad look and she's that's
what i said when she said it it's not
gonna happen just pretend to support it
so that you don't get criticized it's
like i'm telling her to lie which is
weird to tell politicians to lie but i'm
starting from the point of they lie all
the time so why not just say you don't
even you don't even have to tell a lie
that's provable you could just say i'm
completely open to that
i don't know that we have the votes but
i'm open to it it's never gonna happen
that's all you gotta do and even if
you're in a position where you can
actually make it happen well nancy
pelosi herself she's 80 plus years old
now is she really yeah hundreds of
thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands hundreds of millions of
dollars i'm pretty sure um and so she's
obviously in a position where this
really wouldn't affect her all that much
if the policy change was made because
they've already made their money what do
they have to worry about wow she is 81.
i figured she was 78 or something like
that yeah she's in her eighty that that
is really something else uh and paul
pelosi her husband
uh is also 81. wow interesting
fascinating stuff
okay so very interesting proposal and
one that i don't expect will actually
pass uh so
we we will see
what the future holds for john ossoff's
bill
and um we will be back tomorrow with a
new show and a new bonus show chess
tournament today at 6 p.m eastern
davidpakman.com
chess i'll be streaming are you going to
play in the in the tournament pat yeah
i'll play i'm not going to do very good
though i mean i haven't played in over a
year yeah so uh i'll just play for fun
and maybe i'll win a game or two the
problem is that
every there's going to be enough players
where everybody will be matched up
against people of roughly their skill
level so like whether you're good or not
good you'll have a shot at winning
roughly half your games it's kind of the
way the tournaments are designed and
that you could say that that's good or
you could say that that's bad i don't
know wow that's a lot of parody there
definitely incentivizes lower skilled
players like me yeah you join in on the
tournament so yeah it should be a lot of
fun and uh we'll see how we do but i
don't think we're gonna win this thing
no i don't expect to win no there's some
there's some very very good players that
are going to be playing um okay so we'll
see some of you at 6 p.m today and then
we'll be back with the new show new
bonus show tomorrow i will be live at 8
pm eastern on saturday for the trump
rally out in florence arizona should be
pretty insane
but much much earlier than that we'll be
back tomorrow